bonjour café politique quatrième numéro
toujours ici au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux pour échanger
avec des élus locaux des élus de
proximité aujourd'hui françois de ligne
et bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire
socialiste de la ville de guyancourt
également conseiller général des
yvelines on va parler de quelques uns
des dossiers qui concernent votre villa
tout à l'heure mais on va commencer par
votre parcours comme à chaque fois dans
cette émission avec tout de même une
première question sur votre couleur
politique vous êtes socialiste encarté
au parti socialiste est ce que ce n'est
pas trop difficile aujourd'hui mais
écoutez il faut regarder les choses dans
la longue durée d'ailleurs j'ai commencé
mon parcours quand je suis arrivé comme
élu à guyancourt
j'étais en fait issu d'un engagement de
plus associatif est liée à l'école c'est
un militant de l'enfance militants
d'éducation et donc c'est nommé
responsabilités d'élu qu'à un moment
donné j'ai eu l'engagement politique et
c'est vrai qu'il faut le regarder sur
une période longue je reconnais que la
paix restée dix ans ébranlent facile sur
la séquence en ce moment et c'est vécu
comment justement par quelqu'un qui a un
engagement depuis une quinzaine
vingtaine d'années au parti socialiste
de voir qu'aujourd'hui à des tensions
que le président qui a été choisi a
aujourd'hui du mal à faire l'unanimité
autour de lui dans sa propre famille
politique c'est peut-être dans ces
moments là où il faut avoir le plus de
recul c'est à dire regarder les choses
avec hauteur enfin essayer en tout cas
rappelé aussi que ce sont d'abord des
valeurs qui fondent nos convictions et
pour ma part mes valeurs restent tout à
fait les mêmes ce soit les valeurs de
solidarité d'attention portée à l'autre
de refus du repli sur soi ou
d'individualisme que vont vous être
souvent ce moment en tant que mère moi
je suis d'abord attaché à répondre aux
engagements pris devant les habitants et
ça je levais au quotidien tous les jours
avec peut-être quand on est élu local
une difficulté particulière c'est qu'on
est à la fois obligé d'être dans le
quotidien chaque jour à devoir gérer et
en même temps porter on en parlera sans
doute tout à l'heure une vision d'avenir
c'est à dire être ouvre en même temps
qu'on s'occupe du quotidien et du
présent être capable de porter une
vision savoir où allez on veut permettre
à la ville d'aller avec ses habitants
avant de parler de l'avenir on va parler
encore un peu du passé avec votre
parcours vous n'êtes pas politicien de
formation vous avez été enseignant
également voilà j'étais enseignant
spécialisé j'étais directeur d'école
enseignants spécialisés enseignant
auprès des enfants du voyage c'est sans
doute dans cette approche que j'ai eu
mes premiers engagements les enfants
tout cas des engagements les plus
profond celui de des valeurs de
l'éducation c'est pourquoi rentrer
ensuite en politique ça s'est passé
j'avais dire petit à petit
d'abord je suis rentré dans l'équipe
municipale mon prédécesseur jean nadeau
m'a proposé de rentrer dans l'équipe
municipale cet ailier justement à mon
engagement associatif et en direction de
l'école et puis c'est dans le cadre
municipal que finalement j'ai assez vite
compris qu'il était nécessaire pas
simplement d'avoir des idées mais
essayer de mettre en oeuvre vous avez eu
des conditions plutôt idéal pour faire
votre apprentissage en politique dans
une commune où l'opposition est plutôt
faible ça s'est confirmé aussi aux
dernières élections même si ça s'est
réduit vous avez gagné des au premier
tour avec une soixantaine de 2% des voix
exprimées avec 268 pour toi si tu % des
exemples autour de 60 donc je tiens
cette invite au près de 70 alors parfois
monde et celle ci vous avez eu des
conditions plutôt idéal de vie c'est
pour faire votre apprentissage en
politique vous êtes toujours dans la
majorité dans votre ville en revanche à
l'agglomération aujourd'hui c'est plus
le cas est ce que vous étiez préparé
aujourd'hui être dans l'opposition pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines alors je vais vous dire que
vous savez des conditions idéales dans
vous parlez moi je les ai jamais trouvé
complètement idéal pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord on évoquait tout à
l'heure les situations nationales elles
peuvent être fluctuante on le voit bien
surtout si on regarde dans le long terme
et puis quand on regarde dans les
yvelines on peut dire que lui en cours
de ce point de vue là moi je le vis tous
les jours au conseil général est obligé
par définition de se retrouver souvent
minoritaires vous savez quand je porte
la voix des habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines de guyancourt et de
montigny-le-bretonneux au conseil
général je ne le fais pas dans un
environnement favorable je suis
minoritaire donc je sais ce que c'est
que d'être minoritaire mais ma
conception c'est de penser que quand on
est minoritaire on peut apporter et je
dirais même que dans un département où
l'actuel président rêverait d'avoir
commandé t-il de grand chelem a en tout
cas une uniformité total moi je pense
que c'est pas bon et peut au contraire
on a besoin de la diversité qu'on a
besoin de contre-pouvoir et qu'on a
besoin de rééquilibrer ses pour la
casquette du conseil général alain
castel du maire conseiller de
l'agglomération pour le conseil
d'agglomération la situation est un
petit peu différente je veillerai sur
tout et avec mes collègues notamment des
communes de gauche je veillerai surtout
à ce qu'on on se rappelle bien qu'une
intercommunalité sais je dirais une
coopérative de communes c'est se mettre
ensemble pour mutualiser à cette
échelle-là en respectant les maires et
je voudrais aussi rappeler que c'est par
la loi que finalement on a eu un
changement de majorité mais qu'on a bien
une situation relativement identiques du
point de vue des communes puisque sur
les sept communes quatre sont toujours à
gauche et vous avez parlé des résultats
à guyancourt mais je pourrais citer ceux
de man il est amour ou des autres
communes également donc on a toujours
quatre communes à gauche et 3 à droite
et il faudrait s'en rappeler
systématiquement pour la recherche de
consensus est ce que vous avez fait des
erreurs pendant la campagne
alors je pense que vous voulez sans
doute évoqué le fait que c'était une
campagne sur les municipales alors qu'il
y avait un autre enjeu mais qui avait
l'enjeu de l'agglomération et si vous
posez cette question vous l'avez
peut-être entendu c'est robert cadalbert
qui était dans votre majorité sur le
précédent mandat qui aujourd'hui retiré
de la politique qui s'est exprimée qui
est revenu sur la campagne et il disait
que lui aurait préféré que la campagne
sur l'agglomération et il a aussi
exprimé son regret d'avoir été un petit
peu poussé vers la sortie d'ailleurs
vous pourrez peut-être réagir à ça même
s'il dit les choses aujourd'hui sont
comme ça mais effectivement on m'a fait
comprendre qu'il fallait mieux que j'en
aie
d'abord sur la question des erreurs
pendant la campagne alors tout d'abord
vous parler de l'émission je n'ai pas
encore vu alors peut-être qu'elle a qui
étaient déjà diffusées étaient
déjà vu qu'elle avait été annoncé mais
j'allais dire peu importe par rapport
aux sujets à savoir y at il eu erreur
par rapport c'est très difficile de
répondre à cette question parce que dire
qu'il ya erreur un maire qui dans sa
commune a fait 68 % dire qu'il ya erreur
quand bertrand ou lyon a fait un score
inattendu je vous rappelle que tout le
monde se demandait si ça allait passer
mais ceci dit oui après possible par les
maladroits 4 est déjà implanté a très
fortement progressé on peut citer l'on
joue à montigny le bretonneux avec
plusieurs candidats il y aura seulement
deux candidats et une élection malgré
tout comme il gérait venir finalement
c'est là où la gauche est minoritaire
qui a eu un suffisance et j'ajouterais
qu'on a une situation tout à fait
particulière à voisins le bretonneux je
rappelle qu'un voisin bretonneux il ya
eu un duel entre guillemets en politique
un c'est pas entre le maire sortant est
le candidat de droite certains hôpitaux
candy deux candidats droit qu'est ce qui
se passe va forcément les gens veulent
voter efficace il dit lequel je vais
choisir résultat on n'a pas eu de
délégués par exemple a besoin de
bretonne donc c'est pour là c'est la
raison pour laquelle je disais tout à
l'heure que au fond
au niveau des élections municipales les
candidats de gauche il suffit de
regarder ce qui s'est passé partout
ailleurs en france les candidates gosses
sont très très très bien comportés mieux
que ça même et que par contre deux par
le mécanisme de la loi et des délégués
on a eu ce résultat gd ric rac c'est à
dire donc ya pas eu vraiment la campagne
très étrange de l'erreur l'erreur c'est
s'arrêter je sais pas si on peut parler
d'erreur mais en tout cas il aurait
fallu trouver le moyen que par exemple
voisins le bretonneux n'est pas une
focalisation sur simplement les deux
candidats de droite qui ex qui a laissé
inaudible complètement la gauche et puis
vous l'avez dit aussi là où on est
minoritaire ça a été dans le contexte
national beaucoup plus difficile on va
revenir plus au local encore cette fois
ci avec la seconde partie de l'émission
et quelques-uns des dossiers qui vous
occupe actuellement
seconde partie de ce café politique
toujours avec le françois de ligne et le
maire de guyancourt également conseiller
général sur le canton de montigny et lui
en cours d'ailleurs les prochaines
élections départementales puisque
maintenant on parle de départementale 2
conseil départemental dont plus de
cantonales elle ce sera en mars est ce
que vous serez candidat ça fait alors ça
sera bien en mars ça sera bien les
élections départementales et je serai
dans la continuité puisque vous savez il
faut qu'on travaille de conseil général
j'entends que faire jusqu'au bout les
modifications de par la loi c
la modification de certains cantons
c'est pas le cas à pour monter les bus
en cours puisque le canton reste le même
par contre j'en profite pour faire des
informations parce qu'il faut un petit
peu de pédagogie dans ce domaine on aura
un nouveau système puisque c'est avec un
dealer double aval à un binôme
c'est-à-dire un double candidature
hommes femmes à l'échelle de chaque
canton ce qui aura au moins le mérite
d'apporter la parité dans cette
assemblée départementale
vous êtes déjà en campagne pas du tout
puisque ex travaillerait jusqu'au bout
d'une part et puis
je pense qu'on peut dire que c'est sans
doute une des difficultés de ce type
d'élection dans un calendrier comme on
va avoir c'est que les gens sont pas du
tout pour le moment à avoir ce
calendrier en tête il d'avoir donc une
élection dans un contexte où l'avait dit
le difficile mais sans doute une
élection tardive en terme de campagne la
commune de guyancourt qu'en pensent les
habitants les plus les moins vous laisse
écouter le point négatif aura par les
loyers qui sont hors de prix mais ça
c'est toute la région
non mais par exemple on est tous sous la
main on a le petit markets on a les
banques on a le labo docteur tout sous
la main quoi choc ici c'est super aéré
joie des gymnases partouche est super
supris plein espace pour les jeunes par
contre ça manque de propreté je pense
dans les rues ça pourrait être largement
améliorée par rapport au super espace
habitable qui a paris si le dimanche est
un peu
ça pose un peu de problèmes parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de commerces on n'a pas
beaucoup l' issue de boulangerie qui
fonctionnent les demandes de logement
elles sont très serrés ici il ya un gros
temps de d'une prise d'attentes pour
telle ou telle raison mais on n'est
jamais si aucune question du logement
difficile d'accès pour les logements
sociaux on a bien compris la propreté de
la ville aussi peut-être quelques
quelques réponses est ce qui vient
d'être dit alors c'est toujours très
intéressant et l'expression d'aiguillon
dotera dès l'été était forte sur la
question du logement qui est une
question vraiment d'importance c'est
vraiment une des préoccupations majeures
à nos habitants vous dire quand je fais
le monsieur le maire l'essentiel des
questions maintenant c'est une demande
de logement
pourquoi nous sommes avec une crise
incroyable c'est à dire que il ya
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
familles dans les yvelines demandeurs de
logement dans un contexte où on manque
les constructions n'ont pas été
suffisantes et surtout elles n'ont pas
été réparties parce qu'on peut dire que
lui en cours que monty l'île bretonne
est d'ailleurs a fait des sourires des
communes qui ont fait des efforts mais
il faut bien savoir que dans le
département et des communes qu'ils en
font qu aucune on a aussi par exemple
des communes dites carences et c'est à
dire qu'elles n'ont même pas le minimum
de l'augmenter sur voir un ensemble très
très éloignées or par rapport aux
demandes il faut arriver à ce que les
efforts de construction soit répartie
j'ai d'ailleurs fait partie en tant que
conseiller général du groupe de travail
qui a mis en place la politique logement
avec ce qu'on appelle le dispositif ses
deux meilleurs jeux veillera à ce qu'ils
soient pas supprimées parce que le
président du conseil général a indiqué
qu'il voulait supprimer et donc voyant
là déjà en campagne et la voilà déjà vos
exactions je suis dans l'action c'est à
dire que le même manière que je me suis
battu pour que ce dispositif permette
d'aider à la répartition des logements
dans les yvelines de la même manière je
serai attentif à ce que ça disparaisse
pas mais pour en revenir aux habitants
de guyancourt oui il faut savoir que
comme en plus on est une ville
attractive le nombre de demandeurs est
très important les gens ne souhaitent
pas aller dans une autre ville et je
vais certainement pas leur reprocher et
donc il faut qu'on arrive à avoir quand
même pour desserrer un petit peu cette
situation là des efforts réparti les
difficultés pour les communes est pas
proprement sur sur guye en course et les
finances aujourd'hui les dotations de
l'état qui baissent régulièrement
vous faites avec vous le déplorez c'est
difficile des finances aujourd'hui sur
lui encore faire avec ces deux c'est
toujours de plus en plus difficile vous
l'avez dit la baisse des dotations c'est
quelque chose qui a commencé il ya déjà
longtemps si je regarde en 2008 on ne
s'est pas uniquement sur françois
hollande mais ceci dit ça continue non
ce que je veux dire c'est que
bon oui c'est depuis longtemps ça c'est
sûr c'est pas ce gouvernement là c'était
déjà le cas avant mais c'était pas ça
mon idée mon idée c'était de dire que
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'on a
eus
suppression enfin diminution après
diminution et du cou au bout d'un moment
ça devient encore plus difficile des
dotations qui baissent les
responsabilités pour les communes qui
augmente avec même des nouvelles
réformes de réforme des rythmes
scolaires je suis obligé de vous poser
la question vous qui êtes un ancien
enseignant avant de devenir maire vous
en pensez quoi de cette réforme alors ce
que j'en pense c'est qu'elles ont bien
fondé bon alors sur le bien-fondé
j'assure le bien-fondé votre conviction
est-ce que surtout rien demandé et la
mise en place la mise en place après
déjà scandale sur la question qui sont
une bonne idée sur le bien-fondé je vais
rappeler et je faisais partie de deux de
ces personnes concernées mais parce que
l'enseignant parce que élu parce que
militant de l'enfance mais je voudrais
rappeler que avant même que la loi soit
connu il y avait véritablement en france
il suffit de regarder des partenaires il
est quasi unanimité pour dire il ya un
problème au niveau du rythme de l'enfant
et une réforme serait nécessaire pour
arriver à ce que le rythme de l'enfant
soient mieux pris en compte
à tous les niveaux d'ailleurs et
notamment au niveau de l'emploi du temps
d'une semaine est ce que c'est la
réforme alors quand la réflexion était
de rigueur
oui on parlera après 2 du bilan mais
après sur la mise en oeuvre la mise en
oeuvre à guyancourt puisque je pense que
c'est ça qui vous intéresse et a répondu
est-ce que c'est une bonne réforme ben
moi je pense que oui oui le rythme
actuel je dis que vouloir vouloir
changer un petit peu tôt non pas en
reste après et je pense qu'on a on n'a
pas encore suffisamment de recul mais
sur l'intention et sur l'objectif il y
avait une quasi unanimité
après le problème c'est qu'au moment de
la mise en oeuvre
beaucoup ont complètement changé de
point de vue voire se sont mis vent
debout se sont arc-boutés contre cette
réforme à guyancourt on n'a pas du tout
fait ce choix là on a considéré que
puisque les objectifs étaient bons ce
qui était intéressant c'était de
travailler en prenant le temps on a eu
plus de 18 mois des chances de réflexion
de travail partenarial avec les
enseignants avec les fédérations de
parents d'élèves avec les acteurs de
l'éducation et vous devez j'imagine
observé qu'un guyancourt ça s'est pas
passé comme dans d'autres communes ça
rassure les parents sont satisfaits il
ya forcément des alizés sûrement alors
maintenant on va on va en arriver au
bilan c'est un bilan qui est forcément
pour le moment limitée et provisoire la
mise en place s'est fait concrètement au
mois de septembre et on est au mois de
novembre on a fait un choix à guyancourt
c'était pas seulement
de faire des changements d'heure mais de
trappes de réfléchir et travailler par
exemple sur la qualité des temps et
l'encadrement de 7 ans je vous donne un
exemple concret la loi dit par exemple
en maternelle il faut on doit avoir un
minimum de d'un animateur pour 25 élèves
nous on a choisi d'avoir un animateur
pour 17 c'est pas le même coût c'est pas
le même niveau d'encadrement mais
surtout et heureusement ce n'est pas la
même qualité
je pense que en tout cas je suis pas du
genre à faire d'autosatisfaction mais
par contre je suis tout à fait disposé
c'est ce que nous faisons en ce moment à
faire le point régulièrement avec les
fédérations de parents d'élèves avec les
enseignants parce que tout est toujours
perfectible vous savez j'ai suivi ce
dossier également justement en tant que
conseiller général fait partie d'une y
revient toujours d'un côté c'est aussi
ma vie quotidienne et mon engagement
auprès des habitants mais
dans mes responsabilités de conseil
général fait partie du
du cdn c'est à dire du conseil
départemental de l'éducation nationale
je peux vous dire j'ai pu suivre les
éléments concrets de ce dispositif du
début jusqu'à la fin j'ai même été
effaré je ne vous le dira par certaines
communes qui s'en sont occupés que le
dernier mois ou en tout cas qu'on fait
semblant de s'en occuper que le dernier
mois alors que c'est un un sujet
tellement sérieux qu'il faut bien comme
on l'a fait 18 mois pour arriver à des
résultats on reste à gries encore on
s'occupe pas des autres communes une
autre série de questions à présent des
questions qui vous sont posées par votre
opposant politique au conseil municipal
ladislas quoi et qui était soutenu par
l'ump d'ailleurs au dernier scrutin on
écoute sa première question monsieur le
maire vous êtes certainement au courant
d'un certain nombre de problèmes de
délinquance et d'insécurité dans un
certain nombre de quartiers de
guyancourt
d'ailleurs vous savez qu'il y à un
certain nombre de pétitions qui sont
lancés à chaque période estivale
notamment dans le quartier de villas roi
sur ce point je vous trouve très
attentiste allez-vous vous préoccuper de
ces problèmes de délinquance dans les
quartiers de mieux pour des questions de
la délinquance je trouvais des
événements des voitures qui ont été
vandalisés il ya pas longtemps donc sur
les ententistes je suis attentif pour
répondre je dirai simplement d'un mot
que quand on dit certains faits dans
certains quartiers à certains moments
tout ça est imprécis ça ne me surprend
pas totalement parce que je pense que si
on fait des filiales fin octobre bien
sûr bien sûr mais
dans ce que je devrais dire en un mot
c'est que on voit que la personne qui
s'exprime ne me dis pas guillon court
donc la délinquance et non du tout sinon
elle pourrait beaucoup plus précise et
moi je vais l'être et si oui à
guyancourt comme dans toutes les
communes ça fait partie du travail de la
mère d'un élu local donc 1 à d'élus de
proximité fait d'être au quotidien
attentifs à ces questions là et ça passe
par un travail essentiel important et
qui peut pas se résumer très facilement
je vais quand même vous en dire quelques
mots c'est d'abord un travail de
coordination dans le respect des uns des
autres entre le travail de la police
nationale je rappelle que c'est la
sécurité c'est un domaine régalien et la
commune qui de manière complémentaire
avec la police municipale avec les
moyens de la police municipale c'est à
dire les hommes mais aussi des
dispositifs
je pense par exemple aux caméras mais il
ya bien d'autres dispositifs encore ce
travail doit se faire en complémentarité
j'en profite pour dire que sur
l'événement vous vous signaler on est
puisqu'il ya une enquête extrêmement
précise on est à savoir et ça ne
facilite pas les choses que dans des
rivalités de bandes comme depuis avoir à
certains autres endroits c'est pas
spécifiques et bien c'est encore plus
difficile d'arriver à faire le travail
de fond quand vous avez c'était le cas
dans l'exemple que vous donnez sur les
voitures de la vie sa descente d un
groupe de personnes venant de
l'extérieur on le sait pas d guyancourt
toi ça ne veut pas dire que c'est moins
grave ça veut dire que c'est plus
difficile et donc ou travail de
prévention de politique de la ville
d'attention portée aux situations
délicates le s'ajoute le fait qu'il faut
en coordination avec la police nationale
être extrêmement réactif face à des
phénomènes qui sont d'autant plus
condamnable que vous savez je le sais en
tant que régie locale
quand vous avez des habitants qui se
réveille le matin qui voit par exemple
une voiture abîmée c'est la pire des
injustices ou ne rien demander ça touche
souvent ceux qui peuvent le moins se
protéger contre plus de difficulté
derrière et donc moi ce que je peux vous
dire et je leur en profite pour
remercier le commissaire et son équipe
c'est que la police est présente la
coordination a lieu on a les moyens sont
suffisants dans des moyens
on voudrait toujours plus c'est bien
normal en tout cas assez pour répondre
aux attentes et aux besoins
dans l'exemple que vous donnez
de le reconnaître la police nationale a
vraiment mis
les moyens et avec une très belle
réactivité la délinquance l'éducation
sont des sujets qui dépassent puis on
court on s'intéresse maintenant à une
question d'aménagement de la ville
la seconde question concerne le marché
du monde urinoirs marché du pont du
rotois requis et vous le savez très
vétuste et qui n'est pas adapté aux
commerces et aux commerçants vous savez
qu'il ya de graves problèmes de
stationnement la chaussée très abîmée
l'arrivée d'eau est absolument mal placé
pour les commerçants est-ce que vous
avez entamé une réelle réflexion sur le
réaménagement ou la rénovation du
quartier du pont d'hérault thouars du
marché du pont du routard et d'une
manière générale quel est votre objectif
quelles sont vos solutions pour
redynamiser le commerces de proximité
avec cette
question du marché d'aménagement du pont
du rotois répit sur le commerce ensuite
donc ça fait trois sujets mais vous
allez prendre exactement comme vous me
le proposait c'est à dire le marseillais
veulent être mangés vous demandez
puisqu'on va être réparé sur le marché
je peux très rapide
étonnant puisque au dernier conseil
municipal j'ai indiqué précisément à
l'occasion d'une délibération où il y
avait un échange de terrains avec le
conseil général en échange de terrain
réalisée en bonne intelligence j'ai
indiqué que cela nous permettrait enfin
que ça participe et de notre volonté de
rénover le marché donc oui la place du
marché elle restera bien au coeur du
pont des routoirs parce que c'est une
volonté elle sera réaménagé pour
améliorer le fonctionnement et notamment
parce que dans un marché on a besoin de
trouver des solutions pour que les
camions des commerçants ambulants
puissent trouver leur place sans gêner
le fonctionnement est acquis une très
bonne cohabitation entre les commerces
sédentaires les commerces du marché et
le fonctionnement des habitants mais
permettez moi puisque vous me le
proposait d'élargir un petit peu
par rapport à la dynamique du quartier
du pont du retour nous sommes en pleine
dynamique ces derniers ces derniers mois
je pense un peu votre réponse mais yann
clinique aussi qui doit ouvrir justement
alors je parlais l'évoqué au mois de
novembre on à l'ouverture du nouveau
groupe scolaire lurçat triolet un bouc
scolaire à ce qu eux qui répondra
formidablement aux besoins des familles
du pont du rotois on a vous l'avez
indiqué précisé que juste à côté on
aurait prochainement et ça y est c'est
totalement validé une clinique alors
c'est pas rien c'est une technique de
soins de suite avec donc il ya une
centaine de personnes qui travailleront
dans ce lieu pour accueillir en soins de
suite mais avec deux autres volets
également un hôpital de jour ça c'est
très précieux notamment pour certaines
rééducation et certaines prises en
charge et en plus le troisième volet
c'est le fait que des services
d'hospitalisation à domicile seront
organisées à partir de cette tunique et
pour la dynamique commerciale de
proximité savez moi j'ai toujours été
cours d
des pôles de commerce
qui sont un peu le coeur battant d'une
commune et d'un quartier c'est le cas
villa roi on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans
au niveau des images c'est maintenant le
cas aussi au pont du rotois et j'ajoute
que pour l'entrée du quartier de ville à
voir avec l'aménagement nous aurons des
surfaces commerciales supplémentaires et
que avenue de l'europe nous aurons
également je crois je peux dire les noms
puisque maintenant c'était dans la
presse de grand établissement de deux
enseignes qui vont arriver avec picard
et et grands frais ça viendra compléter
l'offre aux lions courtois et je pense
qu'on est dans une période où on se rend
compte enfin les habitants en parle
souvent le tout à la très grande surface
énorme c'est pas bon pour une ville nous
on préfère
travailler et compléter les pôles
commerciaux comme ceux que je viens de
citer une dernière question toujours
autour de l'aménagement de la vie
monsieur le maire l'impression concerne
un projet d'aménagement sont les terres
agricoles
là où est située actuellement le geves
entre la d 91 et la forêt de la millière
projet d'aménagement qui a il me semble
pour objectif d'implanter des logements
sociaux alors ma question est la
suivante allez vous protéger ses terres
agricoles ou allez-vous soutenir
ce projet d'aménagement l'aménagement ou
terres agricoles c'est pas du tout ça
est obligé de dire à l'extrême au but ça
va m'obliger à partir un petit peu en
arrière parce que là il ya des des
propos qui sont pas tout à fait juste et
qui pourrait prêter à confusion donc
simplement pour la clarté je voudrais
rappeler que ce qu'on appelle
l'opération d'intérêt national du
plateau de saclay a amené assez
récemment à ce que nous demandions est
ce que nous obtenions la sanctuarisation
des terres agricoles ce qui veut dire
que toutes les terres agricoles qui sont
à l'est de la rd 91 sont définitivement
protégé et garderont leurs fonctions
agricole sur ce secteur il n'y aura rien
alors sur ce secteur là il y aura rien
du tout quant à la petite minière la
partie qui est à l'ouest nous avons un
peu local d'urbanisme dans lequel nous
disons c'est une volonté un objectif il
faut relier le quartier d'al amil hier
avec la partie déjà urbanisées de de
guyancourt mais pour être très précis
dans ce qui sera la zone d'aménagement
différé avec l'état il ya une seule
chose qui est dit et elle est très
importante c'est même le contraire de ce
qu'on peut entendre parfois c'est grâce
à ce dispositif nous pourrons maîtriser
les terrains pour ne pas laisser
justement à des promoteurs le fait de
faire n'importe quoi maîtriser les
terrains ça veut dire que par exemple à
guillon tour nous avons non pas du tout
comme priorité ce qui a été dit là nous
avons plutôt comme priorité d'arriver à
prévoir et aménager les espaces autour
de la future gare de la ligne 18 qui
comme un sujet d'importants grande
importance et les terrains thales
puisque là nous avons des hectares
disponibles et qui permettrait de
répondre à des besoins dans l' équilibre
que vous connaissez vous savez
guyancourt
j'avais indiqué que nous voulions être
autour de 30 mille habitants c'était pas
un chiffre en l'air c'était pour avoir
les bons équilibres grossir pour
grossière n'a pas d'intérêt et je leur
ai rappelé que c'est justement sous un
ancien gouvernement qu'à un moment donné
dans les plans d'aménagement sur des
terrains que nous avons fait protéger à
l'époque la volonté c'était de faire dix
mille logements n'y aura pas dix mille
logements du rallye des terrains
protégés sur l'autre partie nous ferons
comme nous avons toujours fait à
guyancourt avec la communauté
d'agglomération avec l'état nous ferons
en sorte de consolider les équilibres
merci françois de ligne et le maire de
guyancourt prochain café politique dans
une quinzaine de jours ce sera avec une
autre mère cette fois ci une femme
alexandra rosetti pour voisins le
bretonneux